so the nice thing about edsac is it's a
big enough computer you can walk around
inside it and it has all the components
you would find in a modern machine but
now rather than being buried inside a
piece of silicon I can actually point at
them this rack is the beating heart
this is generating the clock that drives
the rest of the machine and then the
remaining circuits down here are what we
call the digit pulse generators we need
to know when the first second third and
fourth bit of a number is going through
the machine because that works serially
rather than power like a modern machine
and so what these circuits are doing is
dividing down those clock pulses and so
every time a new word comes into the
machine then bit 36 will light up digit
36 on the digit pulse generators so this
here that is that is the beating heart
and as a lovely knob on the front so you
can speed the Machine up and slow it
down
what just 36 have to do so when you're
designing regime tip of a numerical
calculation you need to choose a word
length that holds enough digits for this
kind of calculations you want to do and
with 36 bits you can work on 10 digit
numbers and that was the target that the
EDSAC team had and at that period
machines didn't nipple 8 characters so
the idea of bytes and 8 bit quantities
that was too small it wasn't a useful
number so the early machines we always
talk about the word length and Ed sack
was 36 other machines the time would
have been 36 40 60 depending on how much
precision they wanted in their numbers
that was the driving influence on the
numerical machines so that's the the
crop generators and the digit pulse
generators these two racks and there are
two more identical to them at the back
of the machine these are the interface
to the memory in the original machine
the memory consisted of long tanks full
of mercury and the idea was to store
numbers you sent them into the Mercury's
electrical pulses those pulses travel at
the speed of sounds down the mercury
tube and so in a five-foot tuba Mercury
you can store a large number of bits and
then at the far end you can receive
those bits either regenerate
eat them and send them back round the
tube and then you store them or you can
send them out to the computer if it's
the word of information the computer
wants so just give me a minute I'll try
it's gonna get the key this is a short
delay line this one would hold just one
word of data and each end is of what's
called a Pete's electric crystal that's
a crystal which twitches if you put an
electric current through it and so you
transmit from one side that will send up
sound wave through the mercury when it
hits the other end it compresses the
crystal that makes it emit electricity
what's the third six bit word if that
word was all ones then you'd have 36
pulses if it was all zeros it would be
completely quiet if it was one zero one
zero one zero you'd have pulse gap pulse
gap pulse gap these were used for what
you would now call registers in the
computer like the accumulator the
current instruction the program counter
which they called sequence counter they
were much longer five-foot tubes that
were used in the memory and being five
foot long those can contain several
hundred bits and you needed that to
scale up to the 1000 words of memory the
original machine had it's very similar
but they were mounted in sets of 16 held
in place by a rigid frame for the system
to work properly the two crystals have
to be exactly in line and you want to
minimize any kind of thermal expansion
effects so it's a significant piece of
engineering to build the long tubes for
each individual tank of mercury there's
one of these and it essentially has a
transmitter that sends the pulse into
the tank of mercury a receiver that
picks up the pulse and then cleans it up
and turns it into a one or zero that the
computer is expecting they took the
mercury delay line idea from radar
weather concept have been developed but
they knew it had limitations and
expected there to be improvements and
other kinds of memory technology so they
designed it these units could drive
other things than mercury and that works
for us because mercury is expensive
toxic and has some operational problems
so we're replacing the mercury delay
lines with ones made out of stretched
steel wires the same idea we send pulses
through them
but we ascend the pulses by twisting the
word and that little twitch goes down
the wine have a chain of twitches going
down as far as these are concerned it
could be a mercury delay line it could
be one of those steel wire delay lines
it could be any other kind of delay line
so even the first machine they were
thinking about memory upgrades this
empty rack is one we haven't started
very much work on yet this would have
been the circuit to drive the paper tape
reader and the teleprinter we do have a
tele print own we do have a tape reader
we've been driving those using a modern
computer to test them out we've now got
to design the interface circuits that
fit here these switches or what we'll
call the engineer's switches all early
machines have these so that when
engineers were testing the computer you
could key in an instruction and see if
the machine would obey it and in the
higher part of the machine up here will
be a bank of things called uni selectors
which are a mechanical device that are
the equivalent of the bootrom in the
modern PC it had a hardwired small
program that would be fetched into the
main memory of the machine and that
program and executed knew how to read in
user programs written in the user
programming language which is a kind of
assembly code so this is will be a very
important track when it's done these
three racks are called main control as
each instruction is fetched from the
memory while main control does that
fetch when it's got the instruction it
has to decode it and till the rest of
the machine what to do
so in these circuits here you've got the
various stages of all the decoding and
for example for an add instruction main
control knows it has to fetch data out
of the memory of the machine give it to
what's called the accumulator in the
computer part of the machine until the
computer to add that data to the number
that's already there if it's a subtract
instruction it's the same data flow but
it has to tell the computer part of the
machine to do a subtraction so this
wasn't using binary we used common
oh yeah there is a two-component machine
but this is essentially the logic that's
decoding the instructions and then
working the various units so in a modern
machine you'd call this instruction
fetch and decode again it's quite
complicated because it's got to read in
the instruction as a sequence of pulses
look at the whole sequence decode them
and then tell the rest of Machine what
to do in the original machine there
would have been a large wooden box and
inside that the mercury delay lines and
another box at the very back of the
machine the current day price is about
160,000 pounds worth and quite a
significant weight in its own right so
we will still have a wooden box here
it'll be our steel wire delay lightens
in them here is the second bank of
circuits that are driving the memory the
regeneration circuits and then as we
come completely round
this part presently is empty but in fact
all the chasis are in Cambridge where a
tap is working on them this would be the
computer part of the machine so in here
will be the adding circuits the
multiplying circuits shifting and all
those all those parts so in the
terminology of time these three racks
are the computer would you say processor
now they said they call it the computer
because it's doing computation adding
and subtracting this part in the middle
main control is the automatic bit of
EDSAC and then the two sets of racks
that you saw for storage generation are
the delay storage part of the machine so
as you walk around you're seeing the
individual parts of the machine and you
can tie it back to the name edsac so
we're having a volunteers meeting here
today we meet about every three months
to see how various parts are progressing
and to the swap notes and make sure
everything is going to connect together
most of our volunteers have been
building the circuits at home on kitchen
tables in garden sheds the tools you
need are soldiering iron the Scylla
scope so you can look at the waveforms
and so forth and then we bring them here
and connect them together and see what
happens these are similar sorts of tools
to what the original people building
very much so well John I think you
started your career as a radar
technician in the Air Force which is how
you got to know this technology right
yeah so John is working here on the unit
selector unit I talked about the boot
ROM or the initial instructions those
are coded by how is wired up these unit
selectors when the operator presses the
start button a rotor spins in here and
as it passes each set of contacts that
gets injection to the memory to download
the program it's an impressively noisy
thing when you make it work
left sorry it's so noisy
now hi each of these unit in God a set
of fingers inside if you come under so
you can see it okay
press the button boy and so essentially
you're reading that initial program off
the contacts as the finger spins round
in the machine they called them the
initial orders it was a fixed program
that you how to read in user programs
and it was compared to a modern boot rom
is actually quite clever it could read
in programs in assembly code and knew
how to join in library routines all
written all written in forty
instructions amazingly compact clever
code so would just be what would no be
known as bootstrapping yeah very much so
some of these vowels are coming out of
boxes that are labeled 1943 so they've
not been used they were made it already
written a sequence of outputs that
collect all of the stamps in the world
you'd think you're done right you built
this machine suddenly it's collected all
the stamps in the world no there could
be more stamps within the arm system
then the first archimedes would run
reliably well above 100 degrees C